hi I'm Chris from cush news breaking
news is just being a boo
number of Internet devices has exceeded
number of human in the world this has
rocked the technology world in the world
and the cloud is now being cordeen to
know things here is Raymond with this
breaking news story hi we are now at the
National Institute of Technology and we
are joined here at Cisco by the
Honorable Professor swag professor of
modern advances in information processes
and innovation technology Bachelor of
human design and philosophy human
psychology to shed some light on the
topic of the ever expanding internet
often coining the term the Internet of
Things thanks for having me you're very
welcome sir so recently a new networking
giant has been raised to prominence
Cisco its ability to integrate a
millions of people across the globe in a
vast network it's reminding us once
again about just how massive this
Internet has become tell us about how if
cisco has managed to connect and
integrate such a tremendous network of
things on the Internet
well over time the Internet has
accumulated to become this amazing mass
of information technology that we see
today we at Cisco are expanding on this
network to deal with a copious amount of
transmitted data and adding on adding
new links and new sensors integrating
everything into the internet interesting
so could you tell us about how the about
this Internet and its fast expansion in
the past years well over the years we've
seen an exponential growth in technology
everywhere certainly professor so what
may be the possible implications of this
vast expansion of the Internet so what
impact can is expect from this well at
Cisco we like to focus on how the
expansion and integration of everything
into the Internet would you wonders for
POTUS productivity and connectivity
distinct countries for will be simple
click away working for away from the
office will no longer be an
inconvenience
everything will be better made faster
and easier to use thank you for your
input professor swag back to you cush
thanks Roman now let's go to Kushina
for news on the modern family hi i'm
Kushina from cush news so would you like
taking a few moments out of your time to
complete this survey oh yeah no probs
dad get over you so how's the internet
change your lives
um well to be honest it's perfect for
social networking I get to Skype with my
mates and chat with them from the house
it gives way for so many opportunities
to collaborate on assignments together
and without the internet I don't know
where I'd be I get to share slash upload
videos and download music due to the
internet servers
it's bloody amazing in my opinion about
my penis thumbs up on the internet but
overall I think it's quite convenient
and entertaining I can watch TV shows I
miss and I can share my pictures with my
friends on Facebook oh I also love how
Google has everything I need and I can
research anything I want and even
diagnose myself when I'm sick
so have you heard of Cisco um I heard of
it Mumm corporation right
I think manufactures and sells computer
networking equipment and I was randomly
looking through youtube when I found
this video the Internet of Things
well Cisco plans to create a network by
connecting more and more devices to the
Internet to the point where they
interact with each other and run our
lives without human interference so what
is your opinion on this Wow
I am perplexed with the click of a mouse
answers are literally at the ends of my
feet fingertips this will be extremely
effective in researching my assignments
and answering general queries that I
have living life without human
interference is pretty badass thank you
for your feedback
this is Kushina for Koosh news back to
you cush thanks Katrina now that's it
for a daily news bulletin this is khush
news saying good night stay classy world
so what is your opinion on this oh my
god